[Applaudissements]
qui a souhaité s'entretenir avec toi je
vais vous laisser entre vous je vais te
laisser t'asseoir là
ce soir que pour toi et je peux te dire
que là c'est un vrai événement et tous
les téléspectateurs vont dire que c'est
un événement énorme il est là ce soir
c'est ce monsieur
[Applaudissements]
j'avais oublié ma marionnette oh
alors Patrick ils ont fait tous par
hasard pour toi ce soir il te met bien
ton pote à nous dans la question tu
trouves de plus que les autres celui-là
il est sincère il dit des conneries des
fois mais il est dit sincèrement ok
alors bon alors patoche on arrive à 70
balais on a fait des conneries tiens
alors c'est quoi ton plus grand souvenir
en téloche
mon plus gros souvenir enterré
je saurais pas te dire il en a parlé
tout à l'heure un des meilleurs moments
c'est quand on a chanté les sardines à
Marseille sur le port après mes
émissions à moi c'est que des bons
souvenirs c'est surtout des gens c'est
pas le Prébois c'est tous ceux que j'ai
vu des marées timide du Albert Dupontel
lui là Dany Boon quand ils arrivaient
tout timide et puis et puis après de les
voir exploser quoi tout ça ça c'est des
vrais souvenirs il y en a eu des
connards avec nous dans ce métier on a
une grande gueule
c'est le problème d'être en colère mais
je revendique moi je suis aussi con que
tout à fait plus chier tu peux me le
dire avec tous les deux oh non je peux
pas dire son nom elle est encore
patronne de France 2
[Rires]
bon alors on a fait la téloche du petit
je vais te dire ce que j'ai écrit dans
un bouquin j'en veux pas du tout elle
fait son boulot son machin et tout mais
moi j'ai toujours je me suis dit
toujours j'aurais bien aimé être une
femme vraiment pour la douceur pour la
gentillesse l'exemple de ma mère
jusqu'au jour où j'ai croisé cette dame
là et ça m'a consolé définitivement
d'être un homme d'accord
bon alors on a fait de la téloche du
ciné du spectacle on a gagné la Coupe
d'Europe de rugby en 97 on a déglingué
toutes les plus belles meufs de français
de Navarre dans la nature quand tu
parles de gagner la Coupe d'Europe de
toute ma carrière de les Olympia à la
télé et tout mon plus bel orgasme c'est
ça c'est quand j'ai posé la Coupe
d'Europe de rugby à Cardiff ok ça reste
incroyable
unique bon alors sérieux qu'est-ce qui
nous manque dans cette vie bordel
aujourd'hui ce qui me manque qui nous
manque rien rien si il manque les les
absents quoi c'est sans parler avec
Delon c'est pas de vieillir qui nous
fait chier c'est les potes qui sont plus
là Raphaël on a connu plein de copains
notre machin moi je suis d'une
génération où j'ai croisé c'est Jérôme
Cloclo Coluche Gainsbourg tous ces mecs
là en plus ils auraient pas leur place
aujourd'hui alors patoche on en a pris
du pognon aussi on avait tourné la tête
comme des serviettes on en a pris on
nous en a pris et va beaucoup partager
un million près il me reste je sais pas
parce que moi je sais toujours que j'ai
toujours à peu près 300-400 euros dans
ma poche mais je sais pas ce que sur mon
compte en banque je veux pas le savoir
ce que je sais c'est que je partage
beaucoup parce que c'est fait pour ça je
partage avec je prends une vie
extraordinaire de il le savent je n'aime
pas les mondaines ités les machins tout
ça mais j'aime bien partager moi j'aime
voir les gens heureux autour de moi donc
je fais le maximum pour partager mais je
suis pas un ça moi j'aime bien le c'est
pas le luxe que j'aime c'est le confort
moi je trouve que le luxe aujourd'hui
c'est l'espace et le silence et tu te
rappelles patoche quand on comment
galérer quand on était jeune maman
disait toujours à quoi ça sert de
s'acheter un matelas neuf à crédit du
crédit n'empêche de dormir et ben j'ai
gardé ça c'est ma maman
j'ai gardé ça puis les mecs comme moi
qui ont pas eu de tunes au départ on
sait la valeur que ça quoi on a on a
galéré mais attention c'est marrant ça
aussi quand on galère moi j'habitais
dans un truc de 8 mètres carrés j'avais
pas de thune mais j'étais pas malheureux
je me plaignais pas c'était j'avais 20
balais j'avais tout devant moi non non
non c'est bien maintenant une question
perso toute façon tu as pas le choix tu
as été très proche de Jacques Chirac ah
ouais il y a un politique aujourd'hui
qui te fait encore bander la nouille
[Rires]
j'ai voté pour lui au premier tour genre
la salle genre la salle
et puis c'est Nous Deux alors je vais te
dire
je le dis d'ailleurs sur scène je vais
dire j'ai pas d'idée politique arrêté je
j'observe je regarde il y a c'est
marrant parce que deux personnes qui
sont à l'opposé que je trouve pas trop
mal en ce moment ça va enfin bon ça va
en faire bondir certains mais j'aime
bien Rousselle et barder là qui sont à
deux trucs complètement opposés parce
que dans leur discours il y a quelque
chose de qui prend en compte les gens
c'est con ça les gens les gens du peuple
parce que moi je suis le je suis le
porte drapeau un peu de ces gens-là tu
sais le blaireau tu sais ce qu'ils
disent le blaireau le français moyen à
part que ces mecs là ils en ont plein le
cul j'ai une chance tout à l'heure
peut-être d'ailleurs mais ces gens là
faut s'en occuper faut arrêter le mépris
et il y a des politiques qui ont un
discours qui est un peu plus humaniste
que les autres et ceux-là je les aime
bien après c'est pas pour ça que je
voterai pour eux mais ça change un peu
j'aurais qu'on s'occupe un peu plus de
ceux qui sont pas bien quoi ok alors
patoche tu te rappelles début de notre
vie on s'envoyait un litre et demi de
whisky par jour dans le pif mais moi ça
tu te détruisais comme ça ça fait quand
même non je me détruisais pas je vivais
et ça aurait pas été si dangereux je me
serais pas arrêté heureusement que je me
suis arrêté j'avais 32 ans tu vois ça
fait longtemps maintenant je bois un
petit verre de vin juste un verre de vin
pour le plaisir mais la cuite la grosse
ivresse j'ai plus envie j'ai tout fait
j'ai tout fait et puis c'était chiant tu
te réveilles le lendemain tu te
rappelles pas de ce que tu as fait c'est
chiant la patoche je suis en œil des
gonzesses elles nous ont rendu fou avec
la marine Myriam c'était pas facile et
tu as failli faire une connerie
non quoi c'est vrai une petite chérie
même pas
l'histoire d'amour
juste avant j'avais présenté l'émission
elle venait de gagner l'Eurovision elle
avait un piges j'étais son premier homme
à Marie c'est beau c'est son premier
homme et on a une belle histoire d'amour
et j'ai chargé parce que parce que je
m'étais attaché elle s'est elle est
partie j'ai voulu me flinguer quand tu
en penses avec le recul ouais
franchement j'étais en tournée avec elle
on se parlait plus il y avait ce con qui
se con et Cabrel avec tout qui chantait
petite Marie je parle de toi et après il
chantait je l'aime à mourir je sais mais
ferme ta gueule tu vois
c'était trop beau c'était trop beau non
c'était une belle histoire et on se
parle souvent on s'appelle souvent parce
que le temps apaisé ça je le dis ça pour
ceux qui auraient un chagrin d'amour et
qui voudra mourir ça vaut vraiment pas
le coup parce que le temps passe et puis
ça s'efface tout ça nous aussi nous en
est resté une superbe amitié ça a été un
bon moment et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
au nom de cette amitié que je ne me
présente pas à l'Eurovision je voudrais
pas qu'elle m'en veuille si jamais
je pense que si j'allais chanter c'est
génial à l'Eurovision je finirai
peut-être pas dernier hein alors Patrick
tout à l'heure tu as vécu un moment de
sensibilité très fort ça m'a touché et
tu te rappelles le soir de l'accident de
Sébastien justement on devait monter sur
scène et on a appelé Carlos pour qu'il
ne remplace et là il nous a dit cette
phrase incroyable
je ne viendrai pas parce que City va pas
toi tu t'en sortiras jamais tu vas
monter sur scène tu vas leur donner de
l'amour et vont te le rendre et ça va te
tenir debout
j'ai pas de pudeur par rapport à ça si
une manière d'exorciser moi ma vie
depuis ce moment-là ce soir-là je suis
déjà mort moi tout le reste c'est du
sursis c'est je c'est pour ça que je
suis entendre connerie parce que parce
que tu tous les gens à qui c'est arrivé
savent ce que ça ce que ça représente
par contre c'est vrai c'est vrai que ce
que m'a dit Carlos ce soir là ça m'a
sorti et j'essaie de le transmettre si
dans un drame comme ça tu te mets par
terre et tu dis plaignez moi ouh là là
je vais pas bien tu t'en sors pas c'est
pas la peine par contre être encore plus
généreux avec celui qui souffre et tout
ça c'est ça qui sort moi je suis monté
sur scène c'était un enfer de
monter faire le clown sur une scène 8
heures après avec devant moi en plus la
route où il s'était tué j'étais en plein
air c'était abominable mais c'est ce
qu'il fallait que je fasse parce que
on oublie ça parce que c'est vrai que on
n'est pas là pour eux non mais non non
mais je vis avec
et surtout si je suis un vrai humaniste
j'essaie de transmettre mon expérience
parce qu'en ce moment il y a des mecs
qui nous regardent qui viennent de
perdre un gamin qui viennent d'en perdre
et puis tu relativise il y a des gens
qui me disent il y a rien de pire que
personne si en perdre deux
alors un jour le bonheur a quand même
frappé à ta porte tu rencontres nana ta
partenaire de vie alors à ce qui est une
chose que tu n'as jamais dites et que tu
voudrais lui dire ce soir bah que je
suis très content d'être entamé qu'on a
passé ensemble parce que là on vient de
se séparer il y a un an mais enfin on
s'est séparé on n'est pas divorcé on
travaille ensemble toute la journée on
se voit tous les jours elle s'occupe de
moi je m'occupe d'elle ça aussi c'est un
truc que je voudrais transmettre aux
gens qui séparent je leur souhaite à
tous d'avoir la séparation que nous on a
là parce que si elle a besoin de moi je
vais être là si moi j'ai besoin d'aide
elle va être là ça s'est transformé elle
a sa vie elle est libre j'ai la mienne
on a eu on a eu c'est marrant parce que
je suis en train d'écrire un bouquin qui
parle de pas de ça mais qui parle de la
nostalgie on s'est donné des chances
pendant 30 ans c'est donner une deuxième
chance une troisième on a eu de
l'indulgence comme faisait les gens
avant ils prenaient le temps au lieu de
se casser ou à la première dispute et
puis on a épuisé tout ça et il nous en
reste une tendresse et une et surtout
une petite fille magnifique qui
s'appelle Lily qui est et j'aimerais
tellement
transmettre aux gens que tu as vu le
nombre de crimes passionnés le nombre de
de bagarres de mecs qui fracassent leur
nanas qui se battent etc non il y a pas
eu un mot plus haut que l'autre il y a
pas eu et je suis aujourd'hui je vais
tout faire pour qu'elle soit heureuse
alors de son bonheur elle va dépendre le
mien dernière question mon poto si on se
revoit dans 5 ans
il te reste trois minutes à vivre ce
serait quoi tes derniers mots mes
derniers mots je les ai volés ils sont
pas à moi je les ai volé à Jacques Brel
à 10 minutes de sa mort c'est Fabien qui
me l'a appris à 10 minutes de sa mort
Jacques Brel il a dit si vous m'aimez
ez vos gueules et donc sur ma tombe il y
aura marqué si vous m'aimez fermez vos
gueules ça là
merci les deux Patrick Sébastien jouer
quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup et qui
c'est grâce à lui qu'on a pu faire cette
séquence on va dire je vous remercie
d'ailleurs les marionnettiste
merci merci beaucoup il faut appeler les
voir on peut leur faire un coucou merci
à eux parce que ils attendent et je peux
vous dire que c'est c'est hyper dur
merci ils sont merci les filles merci
d'être là et vraiment bravo et c'est
Yves Lecoq qui est avec nous qu'on parle
bien sûr
merci merci
merci merci d'être là
on est des vieux assis-toi avec nous on
est devenu qui est magnifique toi aussi
bah le bleu c'est pas non mais assis-toi
assieds-toi Yves Lecoq
Yves c'est un des plus grands imitateurs
de l'histoire à l'époque on était trois
il y avait Yves Thierry et moi
exactement il paraît qu'il y a une
anecdote entre vous il parce que tu
étais son concurrent à l'époque
avec sa maman de Patrick ah non sa maman
c'est à dire que évidemment elle voulait
savoir ce que je faisais sur scène pour
le raconter
donc elle venait elle était venue à
l'Olympia on m'avait dit il y a la maman
de Sébastien dans la salle j'ai peur
c'est bien ça voulait regarder
moi j'ai toujours moi j'ai toujours aimé
qu'on se moque de moi parce que c'est
comme je disais tout à l'heure un
imitateur être imité c'est on a
pas eu beaucoup l'occasion de se parler
parce que tu étais très pris moi aussi
et puis on s'est retrouvé quand
justement tu as été un peu plus ça me
rappelle quand même que un des premiers
disques que j'ai acheté c'était toi en
train de faire des imitations de faire
des chansons originales avec la voix de
Intel
merci Le Coq d'être avec nous merci
reste avec nous